[Music]
as Surgeon General of your army I know
that the subject of this film is a
deadly enemy and a menace to our armed
forces for too long we have allowed a
social taboo to prevent effective
discussion and action now it is high
time we met the enemy with all the force
and knowledge at our command I am sure
the dr. Perrin agrees with me I
completely agree with what general
Curtis told you the lifeblood of a
democracy is your ability to understand
and act upon a problem once the facts
are presented to you the purpose of this
motion picture is to give you the facts
and then you as individuals and citizens
of a democracy must take action
what goes on I think if you needed a
rest how come you're not loading up take
a look at that lineup you'll see baby
face out there who you yeah that's right
everybody's on hand with your crazy baby
please there's no great team fire rings
around your Danny Boy with one wing tied
behind her back
gonna figure like Betty Grable and guns
weight talk brother if she's not your
killer why isn't he making a big hot
baby face to be leading the pack she's
in top shape we worked on a long night
we gave her a manicure and a permanent D
she look beautiful this morning the
pilot was Jonas are you kidding captain
Hubbard
he has more hours that he played in the
squad uh-huh curious terrific but he got
sick or something hey picked up some
germ and you know how bomber crew works
they work together like a football team
they're taking weeks to Train another
pilot to us but I break and after all
the work you boys did to get her ready
for action and this is that too we're
headed for the real hot spots
well so what's that your card from a
nice Tokyo hotel arrived safely wish
told you over here yeah I will see you
somewhere
Algiers Siberia maybe even break this
guy's so long fellas
[Music]
I wonder what germ could knock out a
Flying Fortress my spotter planes in the
world
there they go colonel baby-faced could
have been up there with him I kept her
out crew a little bad luck you'll have
to work fast and get you back into
action actually I know I'm too flying
for good I know I'm headed out it for an
asylum or a seeing-eye dog I wouldn't
mind it so much getting the works from a
Messerschmitt or a zero if I had a
couple of good folks at home first
this way Gavin I wouldn't try to tell
you how to a hands with babyface why
tell me how to run my business
what do you mean sir I mean you don't
know a thing about syphilis
except a few good you take it over the
enemy before we start dropping bombs on
you folks here
those two Reckling thinks they are the
stupidest germs the spirochetes they've
gotten into your body tissues but you're
going to kill them before they do any
harm before they do any harm that's what
I said
medical science has developed a specific
cure for syphilis anytime we can find
him early we can cured and the earlier
we find it the quicker he cured and if
you've caught your case right at the
start but I've always heard the move the
kid next to all of the patent medicine
salesmen surely not from anyone who know
what he was talking about 10 will give
me the works I've got to get back to
that thing play when do we start key
you're starting now
how long before I could be around people
less than a week and you won't be
contagious if you keep up the treatments
how many treat you're going to have a
series of arsenic's just in your arm and
business judge in your hip about 56
altogether sit down or up your let's eat
make a fist
I've heard all about this stuff runs
like liquid fire doesn't but does it I
don't feel anything yet but what about
later and you won't feel it it's
painless the whole treatment is painless
won't even keep you from working once
your non-infectious you can go about
your business and do anything you like
look Colonel when a pilot's grounded
it's like losing his license to breathe
but well you've renewed my license and I
want to thank you it's all right captain
be sure to keep up the treatments don't
miss a single one
just because the symptoms disappear
don't think that the cease is gone
working together will clear every spire
Kedar your body Colonel you're in
command and orders are orders just one
more thing captain yes sir name the
first Co after me you're on the PC sir
do you want the facts well the first
question is the extent of syphilis in
America will measure the numbers
allow me to introduce several members of
a local drive for wind art
hundreds of young American boys every
week Mary introduced mr. Thompson how do
you do mr. Griffith good morning and mr.
Harrison how do you do tell them what
you would learn mr. Harrison a couple of
years ago I would have been embarrassed
if anyone had mentioned syphilis in my
presence now I realize that I was just
shutting my eyes to a very serious
condition hey you've got our figures out
of every thousand men will appear before
this board for induction we've had to
reject 41 because of syphilis at first
we thought there must be something wrong
in this district so when he wrote to the
Selective Service headquarters in
Washington Tom tell them what
headquarters wrote back the national
average is 47 able-bodied men rejected
for syphilis out of every thousand
examined there are some states in the
Union however where the average is as
high as 170 men rejected for syphilis
out of every thousand thank you
gentlemen
staggering history now let's visit an
Army Hospital let us check up on the
army itself remember they're still
measuring syphilis by numbers coming on
[Applause]
yes we're losing a lot of men to
venereal disease colonel thank you you
see for yourself every time there's a
war the venereal disease rate takes to
jump it's bad enough in peacetime but
now it's like a forest fire
no organization of saboteurs could do
have this damage to our army we averaged
30 venereal disease cases each year out
of every thousand men in uniform that
means 300,000 men put out of action each
year and ten million men are me and
every one of those men as a casualty saw
his combat is concerned think of that
300,000 casualties without even a battle
well I'm sorry to have to run out on
your colonel but I'm swamped with work
Thank You major
goodbye goodbye
remember the men of our army come from
every walk of life they are true
cross-section of America for syphilis is
no respecter of wealth or social
position it attacks the Park Avenue
millionaires four listed Bowery tram and
now let us measure the spread of
syphilis in dollars and cents and cost
to the taxpayer it costs the taxpayer 10
million dollars every year to pay for
the care of the sybaritic blind in
public institutions there are 23,000
cases of insanity caused by syphilis in
status items they cost a taxpayer 14
million dollars annually another 31
million is spent annually in private
institutions the Veterans Administration
spends 82 million dollars every year on
hospitalization and disability pensions
for syphilis cases amazing isn't it
now let us measure the spread of
syphilis in half break
[Music]
don't worry these children are normal
healthy babies they have a good happy
life ahead of them they're the lucky
ones
you wouldn't want to see the other side
of the picture good morning Arthur Monte
Carol would you tell our friends have
this problem enviros mothers and babies
certainly last year about 96 thousand
children were born in this country to
mothers with syphilis 34 thousand of the
babies were born with congenital
syphilis if we could have discovered the
condition of the mothers before the
fifth month of pregnancy we could
retrieve them and the children would
have been born perfectly healthy
I guess the mothers were ashamed to
admit the disease or they didn't
understand it well maybe they were just
afraid or they didn't know they had
I'm sorry if you sounded bit off but
then doctors see the heartbreak the
staff willing to try to do firsthand and
they know that all of it could be
prevented with ease we could put
syphilis in eclairs for typhoid fever
diphtheria smallpox I'm getting all
worked up - I only meant 2% a fast and
we now know facts number one syphilis
has spread all over America to a
staggering extent let's go back to my
office
well now that we know the extent of
syphilis in America let us consider what
can be done about it sir the necessary
evil
is it something science is unable to
fight or is it simply too powerful for
the human race to cope with
I was born in Denmark
some years ago I went back for a visit I
was amazed at their progress in the
field of an area this season I took some
home movies
[Applause]
you can see for yourself of Denmark
attacks the problem there's one of the
big community clinics in Copenhagen
Denmark there's a young couple entering
the clinic together for blood tests
before getting married there's no shame
attached no questions of secrecy when
Danes or Swedes or Norwegians he event
syphilis is a naughty word an American
to laugh they wonder what's wrong with
us because in their countries
syphilis is looked upon the same as any
other sickness or disease this is the
inside of a Copenhagen clinically
febrile gets regular blood tests and so
the health department's can keep a close
check on any spreading of the disease
thus the disease is called he treated
immediately in the chain of infections
so this asked us to ask is broken at the
source
but that isn't censorship or ashamed
cutting that patient's head off as he
gets a shot of arsenic it's just my bad
movie shooting from Copenhagen it's no
crime to have syphilis
it's only a crime not to take treatment
for syphilis but then you endanger
everyone with whom you come in contact
[Applause]
they don't sneak down bag alleys they
don't hide the disease they don't
whisper about it back up their hands no
they faced a problem openly and honesty
well the question is does their system
work any better for springing the
discussion of syphilis into the urban
economies anything
well here's to assault the population of
New York State is roughly equal to that
of Sweden Norway and Denmark combined
each of the little figures represents
two thousand new cases of syphilis
reported the year so in the last year
before the Nazi invasion New York State
one of the most progressive states and
fighting Sibley's had 50,000 new cases
reported Denmark Norway and Sweden
combined had only 2000 so now we know
fact number two syphilis can be stamped
out as widespread as it is no country to
date we could almost completely wipe it
out in no time
it's all very well talking in terms of
think of some countries representing
millions of people but the question is
what can you and I us individuals do
about it well first thing you must do is
to have a blood test yes I mean you the
need for a blood test means you want me
as well as the village idiot go to your
family doctor hall if you can't afford a
private physician go to your local
health clinic I'll show you what to do
come along we'll call on a young private
doctor you'll come along
have y'all want to come in
don't be afraid come on in
Colonel Johnson to see you doctor thank
you
I need you oh hello fennel what's the
matter need a prescription for orange
juice and castor oil no I'll come for a
blood test oh good idea I had one myself
last week I brought some friends along I
want them to see how it's done splendid
everybody should know all about blood
tests will you come this way well come
on
there's no more paint than a slight
pinprick the doctor told staff only
about a spoonful of life
I'll send us the laboratory and you
should have your report tomorrow
afternoon this is what most people call
it what some insist will you explain
that doctor yes actually our new test is
an improvement over the Wasserman we now
have about five or six new and better
blood tests absolutely accurate but the
public calls them all the Wasserman test
the main thing is that the tele finish
spirochetes antibody that's right a
blood test is the best and most accurate
check on spirochetes that well you see
that's orders to it and yet think of the
millions of dollars the thousands of
tragedies the millions of wrecked lives
which could be saved with so little
effort thank you
fact number three the way to stay
involved syphilis is for everyone to
take drug tests then viable syphilis is
located have it treated and cured and it
sounds like a PC doesn't it well it's
that easy and it's up to you
I don't know about you but I hate the
idea of the Swedes Norwegians and Danes
thinking we're a bunch of superstitious
idiots let's show them where as adult
and intelligent as they are let that be
our plan of conquest the conquest of
disease the children who follow us must
inherit health and freedom and Happiness
the scourge of the seas must be wiped
from the land and then there will be a
new day ahead stay without insidious
lurking evil sicknesses a day without a
useless hypocritical attitude which
refuses to name a germ he had permits
the horrible devastation caused fire
syphilis
sale syphilis learn about have a blood
test to make sure you haven't got it and
working together we will stamp it out
here we have told the story of venereal
disease control untold is the fine work
of churches schools and social agencies
are doing to prevent the promiscuity
which spreads infection it is important
to remember that the only sure way for
the individual to avoid infection is to
avoid exposure learn the facts with
knowledge and intelligent action the
people of America can eradicate the
venereal diseases
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]